-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
This is the show to be at!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is the show to watch!
Thank you for being here.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, tensions are high
between Russia and Ukraine,
so President Biden just had
a call with Vladimir Putin,
and he invited him
to meet in person.
And when they first meet, Putin
will hand Biden a box and say,
"These are some of Donald's
things he left at my place.
Can you give to him?
Thank you."
Yep, Biden asked Putin to meet
in a neutral third country.
Because meeting up with Putin
is like buying something
off Craigslist.
You want to meet in
a public place,
where everyone can see you.
It's like, "Beanie Babies first,
cash second.
You know the way this works.
You show me
Mr. Peanut the Elephant,
and I show you the cash."
But you can never trust Putin.
He started the call by saying,
"Joe, give me
Social Security number
so I know it's really you."
Yep, during the call,
Biden was pretty tough on Putin
over Russia's aggressive actions
towards Ukraine.
Putin was like,
"Ugh, this freakin' guy.
He's like the poison
in my underpants.
Hello? Keep talking."
You could tell Biden
was being tough, though,
because Putin's translator
kept saying,
"Oh, please don't make me
tell him that.
Remember, Vlad,
I'm just a translator."
And today, The White House
said their goal
is to have a
"predictable relationship"
with Russia.
I mean, it's
already pretty predictable.
Every four years,
we have an election,
and every four years,
they try to hack it.
But the president is busy.
It was just announced that
Biden will deliver
his first address to a
joint session of Congress
two weeks from today.
Yeah, it will be the first time
in four years Nancy Pelosi
will sit behind a president
and not want to bang
the gavel on his head.
Yep, Biden will deliver
the official address.
Then trump will crash
a Mar-a-Lago wedding
to give his rebuttal.
And this is big.
Today, Biden made
an important announcement
about the war in Afghanistan.
Listen to this.
-After consulting closely
with our allies and partners,
with our military leaders
and intelligence personnel,
with our diplomats
and our development experts,
with the Congress
and the vice president,
I concluded that it's time to
end America's longest war.
It's time for
American troops to come home.
-During his remarks,
Biden announced that withdrawal
would begin on May 1st.
And then, when the troops get
home, they're gonna be like,
"Why are all the bars closed?"
[ Applause ]
What's going on?"
Get this -- Egypt has
seized the giant ship
that blocked the Suez Canal.
And they're not letting it go
until the owners pay
$900 million in damages.
You know what?
That story was so
much fun for the whole world.
I'm sure we can get a GoFundMe
going to pay off the tab, right?
You can tell the ship
needs money fast
because, today,
it started an OnlyFans.
-Oh.
All hands on deck.
-All hands on what?
-Deck.
-Okay, yeah.
-Wow!
-It's been a rough couple of
weeks for that captain.
Today, he was eating Pringles
and then got his hand
stuck in the can.
"Oh, you've got to be
kidding me!"
Well, this isn't good
for those of you
trying to grill this summer.
Check this out.
-Experts are predicting
a possible pork shortage
this summer.
They say as restaurants reopen
and people start having
more social gatherings,
pork products,
like hot dogs and bacon,
may be hard to
come by this summer.
-What?! Oh, man!
I was really looking forward to
grilling up some swine
this summer.
-Yeah. Sorry about that, Tariq.
-It's all good.
Well, at least I can still enjoy
my favorite summer drink,
a nice refreshing boba tea.
-Oh.
-"Oh" what?
-Roll the clip.
-Running out of the boba tea
was behind a nationwide shortage
of tapioca pearls.
-What?!
No pork or boba tea?!
Well, at least I can still plan
to relax in my pool
over the summer.
-Well...
-Don't say it.
-Roll the clip.
-For those of you planning to
relax in your pool
over the summer,
it could be in jeopardy due to
a chlorine shortage.
-Oh, come on!
-I mean, I'm sorry, Tariq.
I'm sure you'll
find something fun
to pass the time this summer.
-Yeah, I guess so.
Maybe I'll buy a boat.
-Looking to buy a boat, perhaps?
You may be out of luck.
Recent events leading to
a boat shortage.
-Maybe I'll look to buy
a new house
or do a
home-improvement project.
-If you're looking to
buy a new house
or do a home-improvement
project, you'll be paying more.
A lumber shortage has
caused prices to skyrocket.
-Maybe I'll eat ketchup packets
at some of the
biggest restaurant chains.
-There's apparently a
ketchup-package shortage,
and it's hitting some of
the biggest restaurant chains.
-I give up.
This summer is a bust!
-Oh, hey, come on, come on.
Look on the bright side.
You're scheduled to get
your first vaccine.
-That's true.
-Which one are you
going to get, again?
-Johnson & Johnson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's just move on.
Let's move on.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- there's a
new custom-made Ford Bronco
going on sale for $400,000.
Take a look at this thing.
-Whoa!
-Wow!
MotorTrend says
its in-class towing can haul
even the most fragile male egos.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Imitates engine revving ]
Okay, alright, alright.
-"It's got a horn!"
-I read about a couple
over in England
who ripped up an old carpet
in their house and found
a life-sized Monopoly board
underneath.
Take a look at this thing.
Isn't that cool? Yeah.
If you get mad during a game
on that Monopoly board,
you have to flip over
the entire house.
Unfortunately, the couple
can't leave the room
until they finish the game.
It's the British version
of "Jumanji."
The previous owners
must have been pretty wild,
because when they pulled up
the carpet in the bedroom,
they found a giant
"Twister" board.
-Really?
-I'm just sayin', man.
-Ooh-la-la!
♪♪
-Some more important news
from the U.K.
Darius, the world's longest
rabbit, is missing.
-Oh.
-He weighs 50 pounds.
Here he is.
-Ooh!
-Yeah. Wow.
Well, they've put up
some missing posters for him.
Check it out. This one says...
This next one says...
Up next, this one says...
-[ Thinking ]
Oh, I can't believe I have to
pretend to laugh at this crap.
Give me a break, man.
-Next up, this one says...
The next one says...
-[ Thinking ]
Eh, already got a Grammy,
but I'm about to win an Oscar
for this laughing.
-Here's another one.
This one says...
Next up, this one says...
[ Thinking ] Oh, man.
This is the funniest [bleep]
we've ever done.
[ Laughs ]
-And finally...
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
-[ Laughs ]
-Glad you guys all enjoyed that.
-Oh! Oh!
[ Laughs ]
Whew!
-And, finally,
this made me laugh.
Facebook made an error
and removed the official page
for the French town
Ville de Bitche.
The error is being blamed on
a censoring algorithm,
but a prime suspect is
a Facebook employee from
the neighboring town,
Hole d'Arse.
We have a great show.